[Musique]
notre pays est devenu si faible
oui ce qui ne va pas changer de
sitôt ne soyez pas aussi
sûr qu'un homme qui pourrait tout changer
vous les gars je m'appelle Victor c'est notre
chef vous pourrez sauver notre
pays
je'  je cherche quelqu'un pour diriger la nouvelle
unité de renseignement SS le renseignement
nécessite une organisation et une industrie
personne ne travaillera plus dur que moi et personne
ne sera plus organisé le pouvoir a besoin d'
hommes dans l'ombre prenant soin des
secrets les plus importants seulement le meilleur de
notre peuple  sont capables de transformer notre
nation en grandeur,
vous savez ce que le Führer appelle l'homme
au cœur de fer
[Rires]
[Musique]
et pas seulement dans votre mission
vient mais un haut fonctionnaire de la
mercey a déjà été assassiné Je
veux savoir tous  mouvement qu'il fait
Idris dois-je supporter un moment unique dans l'
histoire tous hostiles à la nation
seront éliminés
non seulement mettre votre propre vie en danger
pour la vie de tout le monde
toutes les organisations de résistance seront
détruites wi
ce n'est pas
une question d'avenir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous